[Musik]
ich habe einfach irgendwie aber ich
komme keine chance
[Musik]
aber niemand hat sich getraut
das ist tabu zahlen
[Musik]
wenn man sagt sexuelle revolution dann
meint man ja etwas was total ist kinder
wurden gesehen als sexuelle wesen und
für täter heißt das dass sie dann gesagt
hat mir gut und handel berg war sie
legal
von julia weiß man dass er sich um junge
menschen kümmert die kaputt gemacht
worden sind
das ist sympathisch sind dass khan
schwul ist
aber irgendwer muss es doch es zieht bis
hin zu vertreten hatte vielleicht dafür
sei es ziel geschafft
dann hat er probierte stehen mit dass
materie stuft und als ich was und das
hat er natürlich benutzt ist auf 40 80
und so etwa so ich schließe das schafft
so ein gag sie dass wir daten befreit
körper berät bund sich sauber befehlen
mit jahres ist dann einfach nummer 216
orgasmus möglichst schnell hatten hat
wieder die joker überzeugt sind dass
eine trasse von berlin
[Musik]
dieser film zeigt erstmals wie der
gefeierte pädagoge in aller
öffentlichkeit ein geschlossenes system
aufbaute
und warum ihn trotz starker kritik an
seiner schulführung niemand stoppte
40 jahre lang
[Musik]
mein name ist markus st ich bin von 1970
bis 1974 zum juli nichts anders war in
embrach nicht irgendeine schule eine
sonderschule auf dem bauernhof 174 hat
er sich jetzt leichter
traugott biedermann damals bezirk
schulpfleger lehre und überzeugter
marxist er verhalf ihr geht zur schule
in der natur seit dem auffliegen des
sexuellen missbrauchs ist er ein
gefragter gesprächspartner
ich bin unglaublich traurig
ein lernplan kein lernt sie keine noten
in der sonderschule von jörg ecke steht
die beziehung die nähe zum schüler im
mittelpunkt das im reis kocht und handel
hatte mannes mit gitarre und interessant
ist dass er die hand ins zimmer kommt
und das ist ja eigentlich diesmal ist
das griechische speziell sie das ist ein
fortschrittlicher leere
das einheitliche richtung des vorwärts
immer noch in der klasse waren
mehrheitlich knaben hat er einen anderen
umgang raum im pool b und c sind und er
hofft im schoß kocht und gemüse und so
an die garantie über genug vor schluss
sein
über das wie soja plötzlich den zwischen
wagen und haben die rolle dann überlegt
hey wenn der schulzeit autofahrten
juli nimmt in diesem film nicht stellung
interviews gaben uhr im frühling nachdem
sein fall aufgeflogen war
jetzt wolle er den ausgang des
strafverfahrens abwarten
die staatsanwaltschaft will es
einstellen wegen verjährung gehörte
markus zanker aber überhaupt in einer
sonderschule
er hatte eine klasse wiederholt mit
zwölf jahren aber war sein notenschnitt
genügend als plötzlich agierte
auftauchte er hat mir den
intelligenztest gemacht
die kanadische hörbar zu ihm geschickt
gemacht
hamburg ist für kinder psychologisch
trotz weil ich das einfach noch nicht so
so steinkamp wurde das gemacht ohne ist
abgeschlossen und psychologiestudium an
hat so dass ich das einfach damals ja
also die formierung ski wird meine ja
das ist freundschaftlich repetiert von
12.4 irgendwie mein bier also keine
pläne genauer erfasst werden wir so
sowie schall haben wir mit dem maximum
von ihr besonders gut
oder nein das ist vorbei und systeme
zuständig war die lokale schulpflege
eine leyen behörde bezirk schulpflege
wie ernst attenweiler auch sie laien
hatten die oberaufsicht sie schritten
ein wenn sich jemand beschwert was
offenbar aber niemand tat die eltern aus
embrach und der nachbargemeinden waren
vielmehr froh froh dass ihr gatte ihnen
die schwierigen kinder abnahm
witzig
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der protest der 68er in dieser zeit wird
jörg sonderschullehrer er lehnt alle
institutionen ab speziell die schule
[Musik]
doktor kinder fördern statt strafen
jeckes vorbild die antiautoritäre schule
von samuel in england dirigent zu mir
sehen sie schon mal sehr groß aber das
ganze ist eigentlich nur der ausdruck
dafür dass sie endgültig gezählt
dumme schüler gebe es nicht die schule
machen sie dumm und david opel die phase
der bedeuteten die marke fender unter
umstand der schießt einfach werden
sie erwarten dass sich die performance
von mädels aggressives werden und wann
es mir klingt das nichts machen dann
geht es mit der zeit an orten an
strafbar
[Musik]
also was hält macht er brauchte ich das
habe ich extra das protokoll von der
schwur zwerg voran brach staates unter
die schüler von je sechs zuschläge zu
dir gestellt so versuchte brandstiftung
also
programmchef frühere zeugnisse verlasse
alle an mir scheitern der ersten seite
zwei jahre visitiert sie doch die habe
sie eine brücke bauen wie froh sie wie
die das machen einfach zwei york sucht
der kunde schon nach dem ersten besuch
so geht's nicht und kritisiert und
schulzes iconica disziplin also nun
nicht in das us-werk kriegt man jetzt
einen schuldfrage wieder herbei gebot so
schimpft weiß wie willst du verbissen
sowie zwischen mir und zwei vkw genau
kennen glaube dass ich weiß nie das ist
hat es nie erlebt hat also schleunigst
auf sich das berufs wichtiger teil sind
ja also ich hab zum beispiel ein straße
meister und dem betriebsleiter als
erster schwarzer kann irgendwann mit
einer kita deutschland die einzige
kritik
oder wie es zum beispiel zuvor wurde mit
ihrer sind ja immer ob sie sie sehen
können sie auswählen
der online händler hat der einzigen
entziehe
das ist beachtlich was ich glaube die an
das eigens für die junge krake
das habe ich ja ob er sicher nicht nur
das tue sich die musiker hatte für die
fahrt dings das ist für mich keine serie
die chance to sich ja wir sind jetzt 20
c oder java missbraucht wurde ist ja
auch das rechtzeitig etwas musik beim
nachrichten nur weil dir aktiv mitmachen
niemandem einigen morgen machen wir
haben das vertrauen größer wird dann
kommen sie pcx phasen der abhängigkeit
hose direkt 10 10 mit mir zusammen
sie sind mir die hms oder blieben nach
der schule zurück mit schwarzen ritter
und und jetzt sich mit therapeutisch
schaffe ich kann ihnen ja nur therapeut
gesellschafter mit dem schwanz und
gemeckert hatte mit therapeutisch
geschafft mit mir oder hat mich auskunft
über familie was dank schutzgrad was
machst grad was lauf der oder sind aber
böse element
zu den sexuellen übergriffen kam es
nicht in der schule sondern belgier geht
zu hause
er bestellte einzelne schüler zu sich
markus zanker will mit der vermieter
familie reden
ich weiß zum beispiel dass die
regierungszeit der sich ein dieb ist
merkt dass er hier über nämlich
überhaupt der lärm der opel-betriebsrat
meter also oder flash ist jetzt gestoppt
regeln und ethische frage bin ich zu
nett us bürger gestellt sehe wohin nicht
respektlos
ja das ist ob in rust markus janka war
seit dem tiefpunkt hatte schaut alles
auf das bedienen der familie auf
standardtherapie wurden entspannte wird
im auto hat ja wirklich drin und ist
verkrampft und so und hat gesagt es ist
sehr stolz körperlich gegangen also
sowas wirklich sehr groß massage auf den
usa fische leben also restaurieren und
entspannen und die touristen für und
wider es nur von meterhohen buchenhecke
2100 ist und dann durch und durch ein
mann als lieblich und da haben wir doch
nicht reichen und so das so hat das sich
immer gesteigert und dass er mich anfang
an manipuliert worden
das hat ein orgasmus wähler machen dass
eine seite mit zitaten auch kunde ja es
nicht noch mehr war nicht so wie heidel
ich wenn ich keine aktie
das hat sich so ein unternehmenschef
erzählst du so viel mitgemacht
ja also seine show ist das war mir zum
teil als 1000 schüler sind schuhe für
dich
er habe das rituelle küste das rad weg
zum es geht also halt als mitspieler
electrum machen dass ich selber sehr
klein ist
wir hätten das flugzeug sei das motto
steht das thema jetzt mit einer ablöse
mit sexualität
also quasi dummheit sexualität als
normal ist sich aber zwischen aber nicht
normal sie und verbrachten zeit für
nachhaltiges modell italiener nicht gern
seitdem seien quasi wenn ich nicht
mitmachen dann stau nicht mehr selber in
der entwicklung das finde ich so james
aber ich habe mir mit dem flugzeug etwas
folgenden machen dass die schienen zu
michael sommers
seine eltern sind unterdessen gestorben
aber damals habe seine mutter schon
etwas gemerkt
ja das sei fraglich ob ich da unten
wieder kontakt zu ihm wie sie sich das
vorstellen und ich natürlich nun können
sie aktuelle saga und sie hatten harten
sex einmal selbst hält wort und sie hat
natürlich das hätte ich zähle sagte was
prüfen ist nein ich schnapp hattrick sie
hat janka ist mich um eine ältere triebe
denn dass es einfach schlecht gemachten
und am schluss habe ich mich nie ältere
verachtet weil ich muss quasi musste
eine verwandte sexuelle religiöser
muslim penis quasi stimulierung muss
mich befreien mit dem monat mithilft
das verfahren tatsächlich dreimal der
odenwaldschule und das ist ja das
vorbild sie froh denn die handel
die handtücher dass kirche zur
sexualität sind aus extrem interessiert
war
das begründet mit also für wichtig dass
alle börsen sie die deutsche
odenwaldschule jacke hat sie mit einer
lehrergruppe besucht auch hier stand die
nähe zum schüler im zentrum über 130
jugendliche wurden missbraucht unter den
zehn tätern der pädophile schulleiter
gerold becker der missbrauch fand im
internat und auf reisen statt reisen gab
es auch bei jörg e er mietete wohnungen
in purbach kanton bern
[Musik]
damit könnte er seine schüler sagt
markus zahnd anbietet
drei jahre lang sie die schulpflege
embrach zu 1973 dann verhängt sie
auflagen keine reisen mehr keine
autofahrten während der schulzeit keine
schüler besucher in jeckes wohnung
freddy celik aber auch an dieser sitzung
was wurde gesagt dass das hohe profis
und das was sie zeitlich wir uns einig
und normale schulbetrieb zu stören der
laute zu
wir kommen ja nicht früher fürsprecher
seit 1973 die auflagen 1976 der
befreiungsschlag
jäckel schreibt dummheit ist lernbar ein
bestseller
der umstrittene pädagoge über nacht
fernseh star
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ehemalige schüler jetzt sprachen über
ihre schule erlebnis
untergang ist und ich mir auch zu und
machen ich könnte sagen können sagt zum
beispiel foto vom unter lehrern sowie
seiten so drumherum tun zu haben der
hacker chance besonders akademiker und
ist für sein werk was sind jetzt diverse
missbrauch so wenig mit einer grätsche
aber weiß sie missbraucht worden sind
vorbereitet es ist schlimm für mich weil
ich weiß was abgegangen ist was das für
ein zwiespalt ist was drin sind das
überhaupt
es darf erzählt
für mich ist emotional ziemlich
schwierig das sind alles meine kollegen
das ist eine verdammt verbrechen patrick
als auch in sachen touren und routen
dass ich auch der bestseller autor
foutiert sich um die auflagen der
schulpflege aber erst fünf jahre später
hat embrach definitiv genug ihr geld
wird in die wüste geschickt auf
amtsdeutsch er wird nicht mehr
angefordert
[Musik]
gleichzeitig aber beschließt der zürcher
erziehungsrat einen kantonalen
schulversuche nach der methode von
[Musik]
warum nur dirk maxeiner klar machen
mit einer bricht mit seiner ganzen art
das so befreiend das wurde so gerne
hätte ist trotz aller negativ bei der
schuldfrage
das hat mich interessiert das ist doch
sie hoffen
hans rothweiler fast 20 jahre lang chef
beamter in der erziehungsdirektion und
freund von ihr als aus bietet sich die
reaktion dass jene aufsichtsfunktion hin
dass das hier nichts funktion hätte dass
die gemeinde lufingen nicht einmal drei
kilometer entfernt von embrach
weit wegzug der unerwünschte lehrer also
nicht die schulpräsidentin häufiger als
plötzlich crisis züchtiges leer stehen
mit new york kehrte noch einmal sehr
schmal gehört davon dass sie schon lösen
wie sie mit wirklich passiert und bietet
die seitlichen normalen ablauf also der
schule schon hand und der stark unter
druck trotz minister kanton sehr froh
dass es so eine institution geschaffen
worden ist
[Musik]
hans guggenberger mit 15 die schule
sind nicht um die zks verschiedene
schuhe musik empfangen mit alkohol und
drogen katalogen kapital aufgebracht
sagt ihn als selbstmordversuch kalter
will das war schon sehr starke
depression gesicht oder andere
gewalttätige geschichte im sexuellen
bereich
dann ist nur doch offen
freund hat neues buch von judith lies
mal das tor und gemachten termine der
scanner lernt er ganz toll und zu kommen
der kanton zürich für neuartige
schulversuche zur schule in kleingruppen
für fribourg
das ganze aber stündlich sie sie sind
eigentlich so wie immer doch das geht
für sie möglichst gut dass nichts machst
du mit so allgemeine floskeln ohne
inhalt ohne begründung ganz rtx
direktion manipulieren trennen
denn heimat das traktandiert für den
erstflug 60 natürlich und das diskutiert
immer die aufsicht werde darüber nicht
aus an und für sich war der für sie und
dabei vielleicht mitgliedern sind aber
15 mit betriebs integriert exil
hier wo innere nach links orientiert sie
sind wir sind da für sie und ihr wo er
als gerecht
die achse sind der galaxy wallisellen
elf kilometer entfernt von jeder schule
in lufingen nach einigem hin und her
übernimmt die hiesige schulpflege die
aufsicht wenn auch mit skepsis
[Musik]
die rede ist von einem halbwegs
illegalen betrieb
[Musik]
springende punkt ich sehe dass ich von
904 theke der schule aktiv in die suche
natürlich dann immer stärker konnte ich
bin alkoholiker geworden bin
gleichzeitig aber als zehn ein stück
höher als in honig content also
praktisch spielen konnten
denn hatte im dachstock günstig auf den
großvater gehört es baustellen an der
front in die röhre geguckt wie zum
beispiel hat einfach gemerkt
unversichert sind sie denn den ganztag
macht etwas in die mitschuld treffen
der youcat druck vertrat er war der
jüngste schüler in jeckes kleingruppe
paul speck damals 12
[Musik]
heute ist der 48
das immer einfach umgekommen doch wie
vor unklar
das sagt name und das sehen viele schon
auf ein ja wo sie die augen hat obwohl
man muss sehr vorsichtig sein team dabei
sind 10 13 nicht einfach spontan was
machen sie eigentlich sehr geordnet was
sie machen das konzert wenn krieg da sie
ja warum nicht als verliererin autorität
wenn er so hoch gelobt wird und die
aktion stellten und das projekt da
initianten die hat man also wirklich
nicht und er kann nicht studiert
davon bin ich sehr viel mit gang
auftritt unterricht natürlich etwas
besonderes sie sind schüler sieht darauf
gleichzeitig sind spruch an imz
gemütlich und mit dem hat er natürlich
situation sehr stark entspannen können
das hat wirklich gut da hat eine so
kurze bewegungen die heilenbecker
beschützt gefühlt und das weiterkommen
und dann natürlich irgendwann war ist am
formel 1 großer chor und was man zwar
immer als das was ich gefunden haben und
umgekehrt passiert
man hat nicht so ganz klar ja seid ja
ich habe so viel für euch geschafft ich
kann so viel für euch gemacht dass der
hainich alte armin menschliche bedürfnis
ich meine schuhe denn dort muss er hat
immer immer dankbar sie das heu hilfe ja
und ihr sind wir beschuldigt davon dass
nicht auch noch eine kraft wurde
mannheim mit
er sei während rund sieben jahren
missbraucht worden
auf reisen nach wien mit 14 habe er es
seine mutter erzählt sie sei zur polizei
gegangen
die polizei sagt sie könne dem fall
nicht nachgehen allgemeine
polizeiberichte werden nach fünf jahren
vernichtet der schulversuch in lufingen
dauerte sieben jahre involviert war auch
markus janka unterdessen 23 gelernter
töpfer kubicki stellte ihn als lehrer
assistent an markus zanker überfordert
machte ausflüge mit den schülern
[Musik]
ein wiedersehen nach 35 jahren
die beiden kennen sich vom schulversuch
hans-willi war einer der drei leere
neben mir geb er unterrichtete aber in
einer anderen gemeinde in lufingen bot
der schulbetrieb ist rechten kleist
würde ich jetzt mal so sagt mir and
gewusst dass reklamationen
wir hätten eine arthrose wenn exakt so
wie also nach heutiger wort was ist ein
eigenes programm hand hier damals fehler
gemacht ist der schulbesuch falsch sie
von der methodik von der theorie
naja es nach auszug aus der theorie des
schulversuchs der lehrer übernimmt eine
dominante rolle
vaterrolle im unterschied zur lehre
rolle
die emotionale führung geschieht im
intimen umgang lehrer einzelner schüler
sehr intensiven einzel beziehungen
sehr intensive einzel beziehung er
formuliert ist natürlich die heutige
zeit unglücklich aber damals ist nicht
meint sie im team im sinn
exklusiv in dem mir machen wenn jemand
ausschuss sondern ein aber die idee
heißt das heißt sie eigentlich passen
muss die steuer persönlichen umgang in
all das gibt mir eigentlich der
besetzung der minister auch machen
das ist fatal dass das so der ddr
entsteht und da so können brauche das
natürlich anders denn diese aufnahmen
wurden nicht in jägers gruppe gemacht
mit den anderen drei klassen waren die
schulpfleger zufrieden weil ein minimum
an schulstoff vermittelt wurde
die berichte der schulpflege zu jeckes
klassenführung aber waren katastrophal
wir haben den eindruck dass allzu vieles
dem zufall des augenblicks überlassen
ist die aktivität bedürfnisse der
schüler werden künstlich provoziert was
wird gemacht
[Musik]
die postulierte unverbindlichkeit auf
alles was lernen anbelangt ist
fragwürdig da sich ja als muster
gesellschaft ein drittes auf snort
versucht macht cup ihm dann im oktober
minute bpm methodik 77 der schule ob sie
also er hat eigentlich alles was
fürsorgepflicht hat er ein betrag der
ganz einfach drogenabhängig
aber jetzt schon mit sagt er hat mir ja
auch ohne job das sind für drogen blut
wer hatte denn auch das aber so sieht
schon herzen
im gesamten ort
ich habe nicht
[Musik]
insgesamt sagt paul speck habe er bis
heute rund 14.000 franken von jörg ecke
erhalten
[Musik]
sieht man sich im jahr gibt es da immer
braucht als projekt marktplatz der es
geht darum dass ihm der erste schritt
die sachsen aber ob das tier ein zweiter
und ein hoffentlich besser
auch nach sieben jahren schulversuch hd
agierte genug und eine neue idee eine
ausbildungsstätte für lehrlinge mit
problemen
die medien wieder für mich vor lob
allein das schweizer fernsehen berichtet
neun mal über den marktplatz zieht für
ein anderes format sowie das buch
tradition ist als aufsteiger stück
privat auch der ehemalige kleingruppen
schüler paul speckmann märtplatz
[Musik]
rund sieben jahre war er am marktplatz
einen lehrabschluss hatte trotzdem nicht
heute ist der iv-rentner die ausbildung
der meisten lehrlinge am märz platz
wurde von der iv bezahlt diese
lehrwerkstätte wird von einem mann
betrieben der früher lehrmeister am mehr
platz war wir anonymisieren die
aufnahmen weil er im nachhinein
befürchtete sein auftritt könnte seinem
betrieb schaden wurden am marktplatz
steuergelder verschleudert beunruhigend
die iv selbst weiß es nicht sie sagt bis
2012 habe man die qualität von
institutionen wie dem märtplatz nicht
systematisch kontrolliert das system
jäckel galt bis 2011 als ihr gatte
altershalber zurücktrat
heute funktioniere der marktplatz viel
leistungsorientierter sagt
stiftungsrätin hanna brauchli hanna
brauchli ist pensionierte
sozialarbeiterin mit werner ebneter
damals sp gemeindepräsident holte sich
jörg den politischen rückhalt für seinen
märz platz und ist in die familie und
das hätte noch über das bisher viele
sehr gut 8
doch schwierigste hinter gesehen und in
hätte er natürlich
das lehrling selber und lehrmeister
mehrheit im stiftungsrat vertreten sind
genau das ist das geschlossene system
durch alles drin von bretten alles aber
dort rinder sind in abhängigkeiten
befangenheit den also da hättest du bis
wähle säge zum leiter wie hast du das
verstehst was wenn es schutzschild davis
vor den südast und minister das ganze
konzept die kanzlermaschine ist auf
sexuelle missbrauch billig also für mich
überraschend war das ganze nach dem
motto der mensch trifft und dann noch
nicht genau wie im beruf zwischen
stiftung und ihre phasen immer mehr
platz hatte mit anderen lehrlingen
sexuellen kontakt
ja
mit wie viel
was weiß man es ist als würde ich gern
wenig sowie der beruhigen das land
wiederholt gesagt am marktplatz hat
sexuelle missbrauch werden aber ich
meine wenn bezieht vom platz zeigt das
sagt sogar sexuelle missbrauch machen
konnte berners-lee masters in südafrika
unter pflicht
ja es ist natürlich eines rotors schauen
wir uns natürlich alle stifte natürlich
nach billy versucht passiert
zum teil hat darauf größte hoch hat
zündete der institution sluiter und
jacke eine freundschaft seit bald 40
jahren mit 16 lars der mann dummheit ist
lernbar und wollte jetzt kennenlernen
dieser verschaffte ihm eine lehrstelle
als töpfer
ausgebildet wurde er von diesem
ehemaligen schüler der schüler sagt
heute die ecke habe ihn missbraucht
markus zankers bruder daniel schon in
der bauernhof schule missbraucht am
markplatz zuerst lehrling später koch
lehrmeister und auch dieser schüler
missbrauchsopfer und später lehrmeister
am markplatz also die mit genau hätte
als als umsichtig kriegen wir uns holen
also unverständlich und das ist so ganz
anders ist ja einfach aber er stimmt sie
es verbrauche ich meine frage wie ist es
zu erklären dass ehemalige
missbrauchsopfer zum gelddrucken
das ist nur dumm ungewöhnlich dein ding
wieder sehen wir wer opfer sich nicht
punktlos lösen
die letzte fähre methode seines vorbilds
kritisierte er
aber er blieb 14 jahre lang lehrmeister
märtplatz und er machte jäckel zum
präsidenten seines betriebs jäckel half
mit kontakten und einer bürgschaft
sexuell wie es gibt leute sagen tauss
jährigen sexuelle kontakt mit ihnen
was hat mit einer mehr platz saubere
unter der nähe von innsbruck quiz
stiftungsrätin hanna brauchli sagt vom
missbrauch habe sie nichts gewusst
nun aber wolle sie die märz platz
geschichte aufarbeiten forderte wieso
hinziehen lügt oder gefallen sind nun
seit ja ich bin feigling sie
[Musik]
ich hätte maus zerstören hätte aber
andere schüler die lehrwerkstatt die
lehrer ihre ganze platz zerstört ich
nenne da der gedanke dass der missbrauch
vielleicht winter probe und dann hilfe
den brand völlig allein wiederfinden
kann einfach kraft im kraftfahrzeug sind
dann häufig so wie wichtig das thema
cloud fertig ist geht um existenzielle
sache es geht ums überleben
es geht darum dass wir irgendwie wieder
in den alltag der täglich kite in der
hand andreas gucken berger lebt seit 20
jahren in berlin
er schreibt bücher und lebt von
gelegenheitsjobs noch heute kämpfe er
mit einer inneren lehrer figur
als nachteil ist der al qaida schwingen
aus 14 metern ab
ultras kritisch das sind dann halt
damals ist ein anspruch zu nehmen
nein ich finde das gibt es nicht das
quartett das sich selber zu besorgen
was ist damals sie was es geht noch eine
machen
[Musik]
worum handelt
markus tanke arbeitet heute als
busfahrer
er hat ein buch über seine missbrauchs
geschichte geschrieben hat irgendwann
hat kontakt mit dem es allerdings
ich weiß aber auch klappt oder nicht was
wir damit sagen lassen ob er hält das
sie wochen
es gibt ganz viel grund warum dass ich
das buch geschrieben und ein großer
grund es gab auch noch im gerechtigkeit
[Musik]